Okay. Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Bulur. Ich bin die Diensthaber der Erstein auf der Station und würde gerne das erste Spähmit mit Ihnen führen. Ist das Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, natürlich. Klar, ob Sache jemand hört mir.
Okay. So als werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen, dann direkt Ihren aktuellen Beiswerden übergehen. Wie alt sind Sie dann?
Wie heißen Sie da?
Ich heiße Albert Lange.
Albert?
Albert Lange.
Könnten Sie Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen bestebiren? Ein bisschen langsam bestebiren?
Ja, natürlich. Albert, Albert, Albert und der Familienname Lange. L-A-N-G-E.
Wie lange?
Lange. Wie kurz?
Okay. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 48.
48. Okay. Wann sind Sie geblieben?
Am 14.6.77.
67. Okay. Und 7. Wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Das weiß ich. Ich bin 175, steht in meinem Ausweis dran. Ja.
Ein Meter?
75.
Okay. Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Das weiß ich auch. Ich wiege mich zwar nicht so regelmäßig, aber so ungefähr wiege ich immer 80 kg.
Ah, 80 kg. Okay. Wie heißen Sie Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihr Hausarzt?
Das ist Herr Dr. Schröder.
Okay. Schröder.
Okay. Was für Sie heute sonst, Herr Lange? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, also, ich bin nicht so richtig zufrieden mit meinem Hausarzt, weil ich da eigentlich schon eine ganze Weile immer mal wieder angefragt habe,
dass es mir nicht so gut geht.
Und ja, jetzt ist vor gar nicht so langer Zeit meine Mutter plötzlich verstorben.
Und jetzt habe ich gedacht, ich komme doch mal gleich zu Ihnen hier in die Klinik,
als mir irgendwie seit Monaten irgendwie schlecht geht.
Ich kann das gar nicht so richtig beschreiben.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich jetzt ganz furchtbare Schmerzen habe oder so.
Aber ich fühle mich so total schlapp. Ich habe das Gefühl, ich kann meine Arbeit überhaupt nicht mehr leisten.
Und ja, irgendwie, das hat so langsam angefangen, dass ich dachte auch, ich bin ein bisschen müde und schlapp.
Ich dachte, ich habe zu viel gearbeitet.
Aber ja, jetzt ist es wirklich so, dass ich manchmal denke, ich kann überhaupt nicht mehr und ich habe auch keine Lust.
Ich verstehe Sie haben einige, Sie haben viele Probleme mit Ihren Leben und Alltag.
Ich verstehe Sie, aber Sie haben ein deutlicher Schmerz oder andere Beschwerden.
Richtig Schmerzen habe ich nicht. Aber ich habe so an allen Stellen das Gefühl, dass irgendwas nicht stimmt.
Ich habe zum Beispiel, obwohl ich nicht das Gefühl habe, viel mehr zu essen, habe ich mit einmal 4 kg zugenommen.
Ja, okay.
Und jetzt finde ich auch, dass mein Gesicht so aufgeschwollen ist.
Und meine Füße sind auch oft geschwollen.
Und ja, und, was weiß ich, meine Hände sind eigentlich immer kalt und die Haut ist so ganz trocken.
Ich könnte bei der Arbeit so einschlafen. Ich bin total müde und schlapp.
Okay, okay. Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden? Einige Monaten, Sie haben gesagt, aber...
Ja, bestimmt schon so ein Vierteljahr oder so.
Vierteljahr, okay.
Okay.
Ja, Sie haben einige Beschwerden mit Fuß, Hand und Ihr Gesicht.
Und Sie haben geschwollene Fuß, geschwollene Gesicht und geschwollene Hand.
Okay. Kalt die Hände vor allen Dingen.
Okay, und haben Sie Haarausfall?
Ja, denke ich, ja. Wir sind ganz viele Haare aus.
Ich habe gedacht, dass nicht am Alter, Männer in meinem Alter.
Ja gut, da passiert es ja schon mal, dass die so ein bisschen Licht des Haars kriegen.
Aber zurzeit fallen die wirklich doll aus, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie für diese Beschwerden Ihre andere Arzt besucht?
Ja, ich war tatsächlich mal bei meinem Hausarzt.
Ja, aber...
Und er hat dann gesagt, ja, wahrscheinlich hängt es mit dem Tod von Ihrer Mutter zusammen.
Ja, ich hab das.
Ich hab das so ein bisschen beschwichtigt, aber irgendwie, das kommt mir alles komisch her.
Und natürlich habe ich jetzt so ein bisschen Sorge, dass irgendetwas mit mir nicht stimmt.
Okay. Aber hat er Ihnen nicht eine Mitkamente verschrieben?
Ja, hat mir nichts gegeben.
Okay, okay. Ja, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie, ja, Sie haben gesagt, haben Sie gewiss Abnahme?
Ich hab zunahme. Ich habe zugenommen.
Ja, das passt mir in meine Hosen nicht mehr richtig.
Ja, ich fühle mich wie so aufgeblasen, ganz schrecklich.
Ja, okay. Haben Sie Konzentrationprobleme auch?
Ja, so ein bisschen bei der Arbeit, ja, dass ich so müde werde und schläfrig werde.
Ja, damit eben auch, ja, mich nicht gut konzentrieren kann.
Ja, okay. Ja, ich verstehe.
Und haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, Fieber, glaube ich, habe ich jetzt nicht gemessen auf die Idee, bin ich gar nicht gekommen.
Okay, haben Sie Schütterfrost oder Nachschwarz?
Nein, nein, das eigentlich nicht.
Okay, haben Sie, ist Ihnen ein Öbel oder haben Sie ein Brecher?
Nein, nein, also magenmäßig ist mir nicht schlecht.
Nein, nein, das, was mir aufgefallen ist, dass ich eigentlich von früher überhaupt nicht kenne,
dass ich, dass ich oftmals tagelang nicht, nicht auf die Toilette kannte,
dass ich also keinen Schulgang habe.
Und das habe ich früher überhaupt nie gehabt.
Ich hatte immer ganz regelmäßig meine Verdauung und jetzt muss ich richtig drauf achten.
Und das habe ich auch tatsächlich meinem Hausarzt gesagt.
Und der hat mir daraufhin lakschulose Sirup gegeben.
Und den nehme ich dann, wenn das schlimmer wird, nehme ich das dann morgens ein.
Okay.
Und dann kommt das ein bisschen in Gang, ja.
Und wann war Ihrer letztes Stuhlgang?
Oh, jetzt, oh, ich meine vor zwei Tagen, ja.
Vor zwei Tagen.
Okay, haben Sie so Brinnen oder Sauerausstoßen jetzt?
Nein, Sauerausstoßen muss ich eigentlich in die Wiese vom Magen,
habe ich keine Probleme.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme auch beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Okay, sehr gut.
Und ich schlafe Sie gut.
Sie haben Appetitlosigkeit, aber schlafen Sie gut?
Also, ich habe tatsächlich, das hat man vor Jahren festgestellt,
weil ich Polypen habe, habe ich so ein bisschen diese Atemaussetzer beim Schlafen.
Und dann hatte ich mal eine Zeit lang solche kleine Maschine,
die mich nachts beatmen sollte.
Aber das war überhaupt nicht erträglich,
weil ich das also nicht selber nicht gut aushalten konnte.
Und meine Frau konnte die Geräusche auch nicht haben.
Und das hat uns irgendwie immer in der Nacht gestört und diese kleine Maschine.
Und jetzt habe ich das wieder abgestellt.
Aber manchmal wache ich eben nachts auf, weil ich das Gefühl habe,
dass ich irgendwie, ja, dass ich nicht richtig atme.
Okay, Sie haben, Sie sind gut, Sie schlafen gut,
aber Sie fühlen, Sie sind alltag müde.
Ja, aber so gut schlafe ich nicht.
Manchmal wache ich auf, weil ich diese Luftausetzer habe.
Und dann fühle ich mich so ein bisschen ängstlich auf.
Und dann wache ich glaube ich kurz auf, aber ich schlafe halt nicht so ruhig.
Ja, okay. Ja, ich verstehe.
Herr Lange, haben Sie oder leiden Sie an irgendwelche krönchen Erkrankungen?
Ja, also diese Schlafgeschichte, diese Glöken, das ist natürlich eine Sache.
Und dann habe ich, ja, seit vier Jahren hat man das festgestellt,
dass ich so am Kopf so ein Eckzehm habe.
Das ist so schuppig und rot und juckend.
Und wenn das schlimm ist, muss ich da, also ich muss die Haare mit einem speziellen Haar-Shampo waschen,
damit das besser wird.
Und seit vier Jahren haben Sie diese Haarprobleme?
Die Haut, ja, es ist eigentlich mehr ein Hautproblem,
dass die Kopfhaut eben so schuppig und juckend ist.
Ja, und weil man dann natürlich auf die Haare nicht so gut salbeschmieren kann,
oder so, nehme ich immer dieses Haar-Schapon.
Okay, noch etwas haben Sie, ich schlafe ab und haute Probleme.
Ja, also sonst habe ich eigentlich nichts.
Manchmal habe ich so ein bisschen Kopfschmerzen, dann nehme ich halt eben Aspirin.
Damit komme ich aber eigentlich ganz gut zurecht.
Okay, nehmen Sie Aspirin.
Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente ein.
Ne, sonst nehme ich nichts, ne.
Nur Aspirin.
Ja, und eben diesen Syrup dabei, Verdauung und Haar-Shampo.
Ja, stimmt.
Nehmen Sie diese Schrup.
Nehmen Sie die Namen dieser Schrup?
Nein, Verdauung.
Das ist laktulose Syrup.
Okay, laktulose Syrup.
Okay.
Syrup.
Ja, Syrup.
Das ist ein süßes Zeug, ja.
Okay, würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ne, ja, doch ja.
Ich habe mir mal den linken Unterarm angebrochen, oder gebrochen.
Und das war kein schöner Unfall,
das ist im Wald, das ist auch tatsächlich passiert.
Und der Stand falsch und musste gerichtet werden.
Und da bin ich kurz operiert worden, ja.
Wann war die Sofa?
Also zehn Jahre her bestimmt.
Okay, vor zehn Jahren.
Rauchen Sie Herr Lange?
Seit neun Jahren bin ich nicht drauf, da bin ich sehr stolz drauf, ja.
Und früher habe ich, ja, 20 Jahre lang habe ich schon
ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht, ja.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol auch?
Alkohol, ja, also ich trinke jeden Abend ein, zwei Schlaschen Bier,
aber sonst eigentlich eher kein, wenn es mal was zu feiern gibt,
wenn es mal ein tolles Essen gibt, oder so trinke ich auch mal ein Glas Wein,
aber eigentlich überwiegend Bier.
Okay, hatten Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Das ist eine Rhythmie-Ske Frage, nicht persönlich?
Nein, nein, nein, also mit Drogen habe ich dann nie etwas zu tun.
Okay, enttreiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ach ja, das wäre schön, wenn ich das machen würde,
aber dazu bin ich im Augenblick eben auch irgendwie gar nicht in der Lage.
früher habe ich mal was gemacht, ja.
Als das Kind klein war, dann sind wir mal schwimmen gegangen
oder Fahrrad verangegangen.
Aber glauben Sie, zur Zeit habe ich das Gefühl,
ich komme überhaupt nicht, ich komme kaum richtig eine Treppe hoch
oder ich bin eigentlich für alles viel zu faul und zu müde.
Okay, ja, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie irgendeine falsche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeit?
Ja, also bei Medikamenten muss ich aufpassen,
ich darf keine Kluffe nachnehmen, da kriege ich irgendwelche Ausschläge davon.
Und ich habe auch eine Allergie sehr exotisch auf Pferdehaare.
Das hat man dann irgendwann, als die Tochter zum Reitunterricht ging,
haben wir das festgestellt, dass ich diese Pferdehaare-Allergie habe
und da kriegte ich also sowohl so eine Laufnase und tränende Augen
und ich habe auch Hautveränderungen bekommen.
Ja, ich schuldigung, aber könnten Sie Ihre Allergien wiederholen sagen?
Das erste war die Kluffe nach, also als Medikament.
Okay, ja, die Kluffe nach.
Und das zweite war eine Allergie gegen Pferdehaare.
Pferdehaare.
Pferdehaare, ja.
Okay, jetzt hat man ja nicht direkt, man hat aus Pferde ja nicht direkt im Wohnzimmer
so wie eine Katze oder ein Hund, aber trotzdem, ja, beim Pferd,
ich meine, die Tochter war eben bei der Reitstunde
und wenn ich sie dann abgeholt habe oder so, oder mit den Leilern da Kontakt hatte,
jetzt müssen wir das immer so trennen, ja.
Okay, ja, ich verstehe.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, Sie meinen gegen Covid, da bin ich eigentlich vollständig geimpft
und natürlich, weil ich eben doch auch hin und wieder nochmal im Außendienst bin,
habe ich auch eine Impfung gegen Wunschdarkrams, ja, Tetanus.
Die Impfung habe ich auch, aber sonst, ja, dass man so als Kind halt alles bekommen hat
und ja, ich mache auch jedes Jahr die Grippeimpfung.
Okay, ja, Sie sind vollständig geimpft, ja, ich verstehe.
Und waren Sie in Lesse seit im Ausland?
Ja, wir sind in den Osterfähigen, sind wir mal in Dänemark gewesen, ja,
aber da ist ja alles in der Luft, ja.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich arbeite in der Forstverwaltung.
Forst?
Forstverwaltung.
Also alles, was mit den Wäldern zu tun hat
und ja, da haben wir natürlich aktuell große Probleme mit dem Sterben der Bäume
und den Regenmangel und jetzt zu viel Regen und mit den Borkenkäfern
und immer wieder Waldbrandgefahr, also da haben wir schon im Augen die große Sorgen.
Okay, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Eine Tochter habe ich.
Eine Tochter.
Ist Sie gesund?
Ja, die ist zum Glück gesund, ja.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Lange, habe ich meine alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich will natürlich jetzt schon gerne wissen, was dahintergrund ist
und vor allem, was man dagegen tun kann.
Wie kommt es, ist es auch eine Sache vom Herzen,
dass mein Herz nicht richtig arbeitet, so wie bei meiner Mutter
oder ja, es macht mir alles irgendwie ein bisschen Sorge?
Ja, in Ihrer Familie gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen.
Haben Sie Ihre Mutthalt-Herzprobleme?
Die Herzprobleme ist ganz plötzlich verstorben, ja.
Ja, okay.
Eine Herzinfarkt, aufgrund einer Herzinfarkt, wissen Sie?
Das weiß ich gar nicht so genau.
Okay.
Und ist Ihr Vater hat irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, der hat irgendwie so eine Fehlfunktion der Nebennieren,
aber ich weiß gar nicht so genau, also da muss glaube ich irgendwelche Medikamente einnehmen.
Hab uns, hat er, ja, ich habe nicht gut verstanden,
hat er welche chronische Erkrankungen?
Die Nebennieren funktionieren nicht.
Nebennieren, okay, okay, nebennieren, okay.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder, habe ich ja.
Ja, ist er gesund?
Leider ist er auch nicht gesund, nee.
Er ist ein bisschen älter als ich und da hat man jetzt vor, ja, ein paar Jahren hat man festgestellt,
dass der Darmkrebs hat und der musste operiert werden,
aber Gott sei Dank musste er keinen Ausgang bekommen,
aber es scheint so zu sein, dass der gut operiert ist
und dass, ich glaube, er hat auch noch eine Nachbehandlung bekommen,
aber das ist jetzt schon eine Weile her
und jetzt geht es ihm glaube ich wieder ganz gut,
aber der muss natürlich regelmäßig zur Kontrolle her.
Ja, okay.
Wenn der Operation ist er jetzt gesund?
Ich habe den Eindruck, ja, aber wir wohnen jetzt nicht zusammen,
deswegen kann ich nicht sagen wie sie aktuell geht,
aber ich hoffe doch, dass es ihm gut geht.
Okay, ja, ich verstehe.
Vielen Dank für diese Informationen, Herr Lange.
Ihre Gespräche ist herfertigt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas unsüftigen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich verstehe, Sie möchten wissen, was Sie haben.
Ja, ja, genau.
Aber ich kann Ihnen leider noch keine Antwort geben.
Ich habe mich für viele Fragen geholfen,
um eine einige Diagnose zu stellen,
wie ein paar Untersuchungen zu führen.
Und jetzt werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen
und Wulet abnehmen.
Dann werde ich Ihre Beschwerden mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen.
Sobald die Ergebnisse vorliegen,
kann ich Ihnen genauer sagen, was Sie haben.
Das klingt nach einem guten Plan, ja, okay.
Ja, okay.
Dankeschön.
Ja, gut.
Ja, sehr fein.
Ja, möchte noch jemand etwas fragen?
Ja.
Ich glaube, es ist nix offen geblieben.
Oder hat noch jemand eine Frage?
Hoffen Sie sich in den letzten Zeit hoffnungslos gefühlt?
Hoffnungslos?
Hoffnungslos in dem Sinne eigentlich nicht.
Ich war nicht nur so genervt von dieser Schlappheit.
Okay.
Oder wenige Interesse an Dinge, die Ihnen sonst Spaß machen?
Das kann man schon sagen, ja.
Okay, danke schön.
Hochhoch, meine Ärztin, nach da unten.
Gut, hat sich erst mal ausgeklickt, um in Ruhe zu arbeiten?
Ich möchte noch jemand etwas fragen?
Ich hatte eine Frage.
Haben Sie vielleicht Raulstimme oder Häserkeit bemerkt?
Also, ein bisschen Raulstimme habe ich immer.
Aber das ist ja nicht...
Also, ich habe nicht den Ahnung, dass das schlimmer geworden ist in letzter Zeit.
Aber ein bisschen kratzige Stimme habe ich eigentlich schon mal Leben lang.
Ich war nie ein guter Sänger.
Okay.
Da ist sie wieder.
Okay. Wollen Sie weiter machen?
Ja, ich kann versuchen. Das ist mein erstes...
Die zweite, nicht vergessen.
Schon die zweite, Sie haben schon Routine.
Und ich habe ein bisschen Stress, aber ich kann versuchen.
Ja, also, wenn das nur halb so gut läuft wie der Anfang,
dann kann eigentlich nicht viel schief gehen.
Das war doch eine sehr perfekte Anamnese,
können wir ja gar nicht mehr können.
Also, schauen wir mal, was losgeht.
Okay. Frau Berastin, ich habe einen neuen Patienten.
Ich möchte einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Natürlich, ja.
Der Patient heißt Albert Lange, ist 48 Jahre alt,
75 Jahre alt, groß und 80 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Lange stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit vier Monaten
eine ständige Depression und fertig die Konzentration des Problems.
Und einige Halbveränderungen.
Veränderungen.
Vor.
Das war gut, das war noch kam.
Ja, okay.
Vor.
Diese Beschwerden sind langsam aufgetreten.
Ja, sind langsam aufgetreten.
Ja, diese Beschwerden sind langsam aufgetreten.
Und hat sich mit der Seite verschlechtert.
Der Patient berichtet.
Sie habe, der Patient berichtet.
Er, ähm, ähm, äh, ganze Tag äh, müdig,
ganze Tag fatig, äh, und äh, ja, oder.
Der Patient berichtet, äh, äh, im, in lessen,
in lessen seid, äh, äh, sie, äh, oder.
Der Patient habe, äh, der Patient habe, äh, folgende Begleisämtomen.
Äh, gewusstnahme, ja, gewusstnahme, äh, und obstipation,
und äh, äh, insomni, äh, in Appatens, äh,
Konzentration, Probleme, Haarausfall, äh, äh, und äh, fatig.
Mhm.
Äh, ja, äh, äh, ja, in der Regatidin, in Anamnesen, äh,
ist, äh, unauffällig, bis auf, in Appatens, und äh, insomni.
Mhm.
Der Patient die Fragan nach, äh, höchsten, atmen,
die Fragan nach, türses, äh, äh, Dispino, äh, oder, äh, Dispino, oder, äh,
wurden verneit, äh, ja, äh, in äh, der Patient leide, äh, seit vier Jahren, äh, äh,
hat, äh, Haar-Probleme, Haar-Haar-Probleme, äh, wie, jukend, äh,
und äh, äh, benutze eine spezielle Shampoo für ihre Beschwerden.
Alle Beschwerden, mhm.
Ja, und äh, der Patient äh, Neime, äh, der Patient nimmt äh, aspirin äh, gegen äh, äh,
gegen äh, äh, Sefalgi, äh, Bay-Vedarf.
Mhm.
Äh, und äh, sie, äh, er hat äh, äh, chronische Äh, Obspasion, äh, und äh, deshalb äh, äh, äh, benutze
äh, äh, laktoliöse Schulk morgens.
Mhm.
Äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, bei der Patient, äh, äh, ja, bei der Patient, äh, ist vor
zehn Jahren aufgrund einer linken Unterarmfraktur äh, eine Osthelsentese durchgeführt worden.
Äh, äh, äh, er, äh, er ist nicht rache, er ist nicht rache jetzt, äh, oder seit äh, äh,
seit neun Jahren, äh, ist er nicht rache, äh, und äh, bevor er racht, er habe äh, äh, er habe äh,
zwanzig Jahren äh, ein zwanzig Zigarette jeden Tag geraucht.
Mhm.
Und er trinken jeden Abend ein, ein, ein, ein Weiflaschenbier, äh, und, äh, besonders tags oder
wachenden, am wachenden, äh, ein Glace Wein, äh, ein Glace Wein, Drogenkommunsin,
hat eine gesunde Tochter, äh, und er äh, er arbeitet, äh, er arbeitet als äh, Fort, äh, Fort
Verfaltung, äh, nein, Fort Verfaltung.
Nicht Volk, sondern Forst.
Fort.
Das ist ein anderes Wort für Wald.
Wald.
Fort Wald.
Fort Verwaltung. Der Forster kümmert sich um Bäume und äh, ja, ich verstehe, aber äh,
die Forst Verwaltung, ja, das ist schwer zu verstehen auf dieses Teil.
Fort Verfaltung.
Mhm.
Äh, äh, äh, sie ist vorständig gebt, äh, und äh, sie habe äh, die, ja, es ist
immer noch ein Mann.
Ja, ja, okay.
Er ist vorständig gebt, äh, und äh, er habe die Klöfenack äh, äh, die Klöfenack-Alargi, äh,
die Klöfenack-Alargi, äh, was sich äh, durch äh, exantem Auser, äh, exantem Auser, äh,
und er habe auch äh, fährt äh, Haare äh, Alergi, äh, mit Symptome, äh, Konjunktivitis, äh,
und äh, Rhinokonjunktivitis.
Mhm.
Äh, Reise Anonyse ist unauffällig, äh, er wettete äh, er war in Danmark.
Äh, nicht gerade ein tropisches Land, ja.
Ja.
Äh, mein äh, okay, äh, die Anonyse ist ein Angabündoit in Amethisthen auf eine Chipotroise,
Troise, Hin.
Äh, Sifferenzial Diagnose in Comins, äh, Vitaminmangel äh, äh, Zuma, Spil, äh, Vitamin-B, B,
Zivöv, äh, oder, äh, Anonyse, und äh, Anonyse, äh, äh, äh, und äh, äh, Depression.
Ja.
Depression kamen in Vetra.
Ja, genau.
Mhm.
Ja.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit den Patienten, als ja?
Äh, sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose äh, äh, nicht, es müssen wir erst, welche Diagnostischen
Maßnahmen machen Sie?
Okay, so Abklaren der Beschwerden sollten folgenden Maßnahmen durchgeführt werden.
So erst würde ich äh, bei den Patienten äh, bei der Patient äh, bei den Patient-Körperlichen
Untersuchung äh, äh, worauf achten Sie bei den Körperlichen Untersuchungen?
Ja, okay, äh, bei der Körperlichen Untersuchung äh, achte ich darauf, ob äh, äh,
eine äh, äh, äh, Ödeme, äh, und äh, Hautfahrtveränderung, äh, und äh, äh, äh, einige äh,
Offenewunde, äh, ob es offene Wunden gibt, ja?
Mhm.
Ja, äh, vorhanden sind.
Wunach gucken Sie noch oder was untersuchen Sie noch im ersten Durchgang?
Ja, ich werde, äh, ich werde so als Vitalparameter äh, gucken.
Ja, eben.
Was erwarten Sie da?
Ja, äh, Vitalparameter.
Mhm, was erwarten Sie?
Ja, ich war, äh, ich war, äh, äh, nicht äh, besondere, äh, Seichen, äh, manchmal äh, äh, ja,
keine Fieber oder keine Haarschlag, ja, Brett Cardi.
Ja, Brett Cardi.
Äh, äh, genau, also er wird vielleicht ein bisschen langsamer unterwegs, dann, ja?
Ja, äh, okay.
Äh, und äh, worauf gucken Sie noch im Rahmen der Erstuntersuchung?
Äh, erste Untersuchung bei der Köpferli, untersuchen Sie.
Ja.
Ja, der Patient kann äh, Haarspfeil, äh, und äh, mit äh, Augenbohje äh, Augenbrauen, ob die auch ausfallen, ja?
Worauf gucken Sie noch?
Äh, exultanmus, äh, nochmal?
Ja, ich habe Schichtrüsepipatio.
Okay, ja, das, das ist eins.
Aber ich, ich wollte jetzt noch eigentlich auch etwas anderes aus.
Ja, bei der Augen äh, der Patient äh, kann äh, äh exultanmus, aber äh.
Und auch, ob der Glux-Augen hat, ja?
Ja.
Ja, ob die Augen vorstehen, ja?
Das ist eine Sache.
Und äh, dann gibt es noch neurologischen Aspekt.
Äh, bei neurologischen äh, der Patient äh, habe äh, Paristisie, äh, nein.
Hat er nicht geschildert.
Aber?
Sie haben Konzentration, Probleme.
Das hat, das hat er ja, ja.
Aber äh, was erwarten wir, wenn wir die Hypothorioser haben?
Äh, Obsipation.
Ja, gut, das können wir nicht gut äh, untersuchen.
Äh, ja, ja, ich verstehe.
Hyponetik.
Also, es geht darum, es geht darum, ob der Unterumständenverzögerte Reflexe auch hat.
Nicht nur ein langsames Herz.
Ja.
Sondern, dass der auch vielleicht ein bisschen Träge reagiert,
wenn man ihn triggert irgendwie, ne?
Okay.
Gut.
Ja.
So, was machen Sie denn noch mit den Patienten?
Ja, äh, und ich würde äh, einige Laborparameter äh, veranlassen.
Äh, zum Beispiel äh, für diesen Fall äh, ich würde äh,
äh, Träuden äh, Träuden, Träuden, Hormone äh, kontrollieren.
Alle Fälle, ja.
Mhm.
Ja, äh, und äh, ich würde auch äh, Vitaminparameter äh, äh.
Auch interessant, ja, genau, ob der eine Hypovitaminose hat, ja.
Ja, äh, mhm.
Und äh, eine großes Blutbild, Entschündungparameter und äh, Nieren und äh, ja, Nieren und äh,
Leberwerte und Elektrikte bestimmen lassen.
Natürlich, CHF, T, F4 und äh, FT, äh, drei kontrollieren.
Mhm.
Dann äh, bei der operativen Unterzuhung, äh, würde ich so als äh, eine äh, Träuden-Zonografie
äh, durchführen.
Mhm.
Äh, und ja, äh, dann gegebenenfalls ein City äh,
Sehr gut, ja.
Und wenn dann noch irgendwas auffällig ist bei der City, was würde man dann als nächstes
Verfahren machen?
Äh, ein Marty.
Nee, das ist dann schon eher etwas Invasiveres.
Ja, Bio-Psy.
Ja, genau.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ja, ja.
Okay, ähm, äh, ja, ist alles gekommen.
Also, eigentlich, äh, haben wir, haben wir alles äh, Therapie.
Ja, genau, äh, das wäre jetzt noch interessant.
Die Therapie ist ja eigentlich denkbar einfach, ne?
Ja, äh, meine Verdacht, die haben uns bestätigen, äh, Vorschlage, äh,
Schlage ich vor?
Ja, Schlage ich vor, äh, eine medikamentöse Therapie, äh, sollt, äh,
äh, mit Ertragsinn, äh, jeden Abend, jeden Morgen äh, noch Tag, äh, ja, äh,
und äh, äh, ja.
Und dann kontrolliert der Parameter natürlich, ne?
Ja, ja.
Ja, die Prüfer haben noch drei Zusatzfragen gehabt.
Ja.
Sie haben gefragt, ähm, wie die Schilitrosen-Untersuchung die Manuelle
abnimmt.
Ja, äh, wie, äh, der Patient steht hinter der, äh, Patienten.
Der Arzt steht hinter dem Patienten.
Ja, Arzt, äh, hinter.
Er steht hinter der, äh, Patienten und papiere die Schildrosen, äh, mit
Finger.
Mit den Händen, ja, genau.
Äh, und der Patient schulkt.
Ja, sehr gut.
Ja.
Okay, gut, ja, also gut.
Wie heißt die Vergrößerung der Schildrosen, umgangspaclich,
im Deutschen?
Schildrosen?
Ja, die Hände.
Ja, ja, eigentlich, ich bin nicht erinnert.
Ja, Strummer, ja, Strummer.
Strummer, oder?
Also, in der Umgangssprache?
Ja.
Noch ein schönes Wort.
Croft, croft, croft.
Genau, kein schönes Wort.
Croft, grünen wir so vom Truder an oder, ja, so bei den
Hühnern, wenn die, wenn die so, äh, Körnchen aufbewahren,
ja, ein Croft, kein schönes Wort, ja, genau.
Das war da eine Frage, dann?
Ja, die Prüfe haben noch gefragt nach der Zepaptherapie.
Das ist etwas, was Sie im Oberarztgespräch gar nicht
erwähnt haben.
Ja, dass der Patient eine Zepaptherapie hatte,
die aber nicht weiter geführt hat.
Und insofern, das war eigentlich das Einzige,
wo ich inhaltlich nicht so ganz mit Ihnen einfach dachten war.
Der Patient hat ja gesagt, er ist müde den ganzen Tag
und dann haben Sie gesagt, er leidet unter Insomnie.
Aber er schläft ja schlecht, weil er diese, weil er diese
Stapapneu hat.
Ja, ja.
Ja, und er hat die, er hat die Therapie mit der Zepaptherapie,
hat er abgebrochen.
Ja, weil es unbequemlästig und, und mit Geräuschen verbunden
war.
Ja.
Das ist natürlich nochmal so ein zusätzliches Ding,
was Müdigkeit auch nochmal triggert.
Ja.
Und diese, diese Tagesmüdigkeit, so ein bisschen erklärt.
Ja, ich habe ja nicht sagen meinen.
Das haben Sie nicht gesagt.
Ja.
Aber die Prüfer haben eben tatsächlich in diesem Fall
nachgefragt, nach der Zepaptherapie.
Können Sie dazu etwas erklären?
Zepaptherapie, ja.
Ja, ein Patient jeden Abend,
wenn sie eine spezielle Gerat für ihre Schlafen.
Schlafen, ja.
Wenn Patienten eine Atemstil.
Ja, Aussätze haben, ja, genau.
Ja.
Mit dieser, mit Hilfe dieser Gerat.
Dieses Gerät, ja.
Dieses Gerät.
Ihre Atem.
Wird wieder angebrochen, wie zu sagen.
Ja, ja.
Um.
Ja, genau.
Und eigentlich ist der Effekt schon der,
dass die Patienten, die vorher diese Tagesmüdigkeit
hatten, besser durch den Tag kommen,
weil sie ausgeschlafen sind,
weil sie nachts nicht diese Pseudo-Wachfarben haben.
Genau.
Ja, gut.
Also, wie gesagt, das war das Einzige, wo ich sagen würde,
das fand ich jetzt nicht so perfekt in der Wiedergabe.
Alles andere, würde ich sagen, war eine sehr schöne,
das sehr schönes Arzt-Artsgespräch.
Natürlich, das ist immer so.
Es ist einfacher, den Fragenkatalog durchzugehen.
Und, was, was ich derjenige zu sein, der die Fragen stellt
und Antworten zu bekommen, was ich mir da wünschen würde
und was ich Ihnen empfehlen würde,
sich da noch ein bisschen was zu überlegen.
Das ist was, was ich fast immer sage,
haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie.
Ja.
Irgendwann einmal haben Sie es gemerkt,
dass das schon das x-te Mal war
und haben dann gesagt, ist Ihnen aufgefallen das?
Aber das ist schon so, dass das angenehm ist,
wenn da mal eine andere Formulierung kommt.
Und das muss man wirklich gezielt sich überlegen,
weil man sonst einfach nicht auf die Idee kommt.
Man fragt ja einfach seinen Katalog ab.
Und, ja, das ist halt anders,
als wenn der Patient Kreuzchen macht.
Trift folgendes für Sie zu.
Peng, peng, peng.
Und Sie müssten das halt jedes Mal in eine Frage verpacken.
Und das ist einfach nur so eine kleine Übung,
dass man sich Sachen überlegt,
dass man da vielleicht nochmal etwas anderes formuliert.
Ihre Aussprache ist ausgesprochen gut.
Sie sprechen wirklich, wirklich sehr gut Deutsch.
Und man kann sie sehr gut verstehen.
Und Sie machen sehr wenig Grammatik.
Also gar keine würde ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Aber das ist alles wirklich so,
dass man sehr gut mitleben kann.
Und, ja, ein bisschen äh ist auch dazwischen,
gerade im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Aber auch das ist ein Klassiker.
Das hören Sie bei mir selber natürlich auch,
dass ich das auch immer wieder mache.
Ich erzähle das auch jedes Mal.
Ich stehe auch dazu.
Ich weiß, dass wir auch für Muttersprachler machen
genau die gleichen Fehler wie alle anderen Leute auch.
Aber man kann das ja ein klein bisschen kontrollieren.
Und wenn ich mich sehr anstrengen,
wenn ich mich sehr gut konzentriere,
dann schaffe ich das auch mal ohne so ein halben Abend
durchzuklingen.
Aber es ist schon, es ist schon ein bisschen schwierig.
Und es ist nur in dem Augenblick,
wo Sie verstärkt nach Wörtern suchen
und wo Sie jetzt etwas erklären sollen.
Eine Nachfrage, auf die Sie nicht so zwingend gefasst sind.
Da neigt man dann natürlich dazu,
dieses Äh, so als Füller mit reinzubringen,
dass man nicht so merkt,
dass man jetzt irgendwie so nach Wörtern sucht.
Aber ich würde schon sagen,
dass das eine sehr, sehr gute Vorstellung war.
Wann machen Sie Ihre Prüfung? Wissen Sie schon?
Ja, ich habe am 9. August, ich habe sehr cool sein.
Ein Termin. Und wo?
Ja, in Stuttgart.
Aber ich denke, Sie können da wirklich
sehr, sehr entspannt hingehen.
Weil Sie wirklich eine sehr schöne Anamnese gemacht haben
und auch sprachlich wirklich auf einen ganz
sicheren Terror bewegen.
Da brauchen Sie wirklich nicht besorgt zu sein.
Ja?
Danke.
Dann mit etwas chaotischem Anfang
haben wir jetzt doch noch ein gutes Ende gefunden.
Ich wünsche Ihnen allen einen guten Abend.